>> INTERRUPTED COMING OUT DURIN
ASSOCIATES FOR AMERICA FOR
INDOCTRINATING YOUTH WITH HATE.
RICHARD TORRES BLESSING THE
GROUP AND SAYING, "AND ISRAEL
HATE IN THE STORY OF A LARGER
FACTOR FREELY IN ACADEMIA,
SOCIAL MEDIA, AND THE POLITICAL
ARENA AND ELSEWHERE.
IT IS A PROPER GOODBYE ANSWER T
UNIX, AMPLIFIED BY ENABLERS IN
THE OFFICE AND SUPPLIED BY
GOVERNMENT AND CIVIL SOCIETY."
HERE HERE.
AND HERE'S A QUESTION FOR YOU,
HAROLD:  IS IT YOUR FAULT IF YO
ARE BRAINWASHED?
OR SHOULD WE FOCUS LESS ON THE
INDOCTRINATED AND RUN THE
INDOCTRINATED IS?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
I THINK -- I THINK IT DEPENDS O
THE LEVEL.
I THINK TO RICHARD TORRES I
THINK IS ONE OF THE MOST
THOUGHTFUL AND SMARTEST YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THE CONGRESS.
HE'S A YOUNG GUY.
HE'S A DEMOCRAT BUT HE THINKS S
BROADLY ON A LOT OF THESE
ISSUES.
EDUCATION AND NON-SECURITY.
'S PART ABOUT ACADEMIA, IT
CONCERNS ME.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS HAPPENED.
YOU HAVE A THEORY THAT MAY BE
RIGHT, GREG, BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING WE HAVE TO ADDRESS AS
A SOCIETY, HOW ARE INSTITUTIONS
OF HIGHER LEARNING WHAT THEY
MIGHT BE TEACHING AND HOW THEY
ARE TEACHING AND I HOPE THEY DO
SOME TASK FORCE HERE TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THEY NEED TO DO
DIFFERENT BECAUSE CLEARLY THEY
NEED TO DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
DANA, WHEN THIS ISSUE IN THE
MIDDLE EAST HAS BEEN 50-60 YEAR
EASILY.
AND IT IS SO AMAZING HOW
POSITIVELY CERTAIN HOW
ABSOLUTELY CERTAIN, COLLEGE
FRESHMEN ARE ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
>> RIGHT.
>> THAT THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHO
THE VILLAIN IS, EVEN THOUGH YOU
KNOW NOT GOING BACK TO HENRY
KISSINGER EVERYBODY WAS
CONFUSED.
>> EVEN LONGER, 85 YEARS, I
WOULD PUT AT THAT.
AND I AM TIRED OF LISTENING
TO 19-YEAR-OLDS.
I DON'T NEED TO BE CONDESCENDED
TO BY THEM BUT YOU ARE ADULT AN
MEMBER OF CONGRESS, AMEN PART O
THIS CORE, YES, YOU DESERVE TO
BE LISTENED TO AND CRITICIZED.
IF YOU ARE IN "THE SQUAD" AND
THE FORCING OF YOUR MOUTH THIS
ONE IS NOT WE HAVE TO GET THE
AMERICANS BACK, THEN SOMETHING
IS WRONG, BECAUSE AMERICANS WER
KILLED AND AMERICANS ARE BEING
HELD HOSTAGE.
IN ADDITION, TWO CORRESPOND COR
BUSH AND SOMMER LEE, WILL I
SPEAK TO THEIR HOMETOWN JEWISH
NEWSPAPERS THAT IS IN PITTSBURG
AND ST. LOUIS.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT, THEY PAY YOU
SALARY.
THE FEDERAL TAXPAYER.
AND IF YOU ARE GOING TO GO OUT
THERE AND SEE WHAT YOU ARE GOIN
TO SAY, ABOUT WHAT YOU THINK
SHOULD HAPPEN IN THE MIDDLE EAS
YOU SHOULD AT LEAST BE WILLING
TO DO AN INTERVIEW WITH THE FRE
PRESS HERE AT HOME IN YOUR
DISTRICTS.
JUST, TOWARDS THIS GREAT QUOTE
THAT I READ, IT SEEMS LIKE HE'S
SAYING THAT THESE STUDENTS ARE
BEING EXPLOITED BY LARGER
ENTITIES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT ASTROTURF
INCOME IS SO THAT THERE IS A
LARGER ORGANIZATION BEHIND THIS
OR SOMETHING.
>> YEAH, AND I THINK, WHO WAS I
THAT AFTER?
WAS IT SENATOR HOLLY, BACK AT
THE BEGINNING, ABOUT WHO'S
ORGANIZING ALL THIS STUFF?
WHO'S BEHIND IT, WHO'S PAYING
PEOPLE?
BUT HERE'S THE ISSUE:  YOU KNOW
IN THE 60s EVERYBODY ON THE
LEFT WAS A -- WAS FOR PEACE,
EVERYTHING SHOULD BE PEACEFUL,
WITH PEACE AND LOVE.
NOW THERE IS A 180.
NOW THEY ARE, YOU KNOW OKAY IF
THEY ARE KING BABY, WELL, MAYBE
YOU ASKED FOR IT AND HOW IS
SAYING IS ANYTHING MORE CRUEL
THAN SINGLE MOTHER YOU HAD A
COMMIT BECAUSE OF WHO YOU ARE,
YOU RUN ON YOURSELF.
YOU KNOW, I AM THRILLED TO READ
THIS ABOUT HIM.
AND I'M THRILLED TO READ THE
FACT THAT SOMEBODY IS SAYING,
LOOK AT THE FACTS.
I DON'T CARE IF YOU BEEN
BRAINWASHED.
CAN YOU SEE THIS?
YOU KNOW SO WHAT IF YOU BEEN
BRAINWASHED, THE FACTS ARE THE
FACTS.
YOU, JESSICA TORRES ALSO POSTED
ON X THAT THERE WAS A INTERTIDA
RAVE THAT WILL BE CELEBRATING I
IT -- THE ATROCITIES IN NEW YOR
THIS WEEK.
>> SO I HAD THE FBI ALL OVER
THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FBI DOING
IF IN A WATER DEMONSTRATION, I
WILL BE DIRECTING MY BUREAU TO
SET UP A UNIVERSITY TASK FORCE,
GREG, BECAUSE THESE ARE MY
DRESSES AND IVY LEAGUE.
THEY ARE FUNDED FROM THESE
OIL-RICH KINGDOMS AND THEY ARE
INDOCTRINATING OUR COLLEGE
STUDENTS PICK INVITE IS ALWAYS
TALKING ABOUT ULTRA DR. ULTRA
MEGA, WHAT ABO